one of the fastest growing economies in
Asia Bangladesh is facing its worst
electricity crisis in a decade it's
compounded by the rising cost of living
a fuel shortage and allegations of
corruption in a multi-billion dollar
upgrade to energy infrastructure
public anger is growing
[Music]
we're protesting about the frequent
power Cuts they promise to provide
electricity to every home but instead
they have increased electricity tariffs
where has all the money gone if they
come from the country they should resign
last year the government pledged to link
every household to the National Grid but
the ambitious development plan has
stalled
for a month now major cities
rural areas across the country
City for several hours a day
and the power shortage is a major blow
to the country's industrial sector
tariffs have gone up several times in
past few years and soaring temperature
have increased demand
we can't run our businesses properly
because of the power outages so
customers don't come and all of us
suffer doing the hot weather it's very
difficult time
operating units at several power plants
were shut down this month because of the
full shortage Business Leaders say the
government should have tapped domestic
coal and gas resources instead of
relying on Imports which have drained
foreign currency reserves one month for
the past month production has been
hampered and costs have increased many
Industries are managing with diesel
generators but it costs twice as much as
electricity from the grid
the textile sector which accounts for
more than 80 percent of Bangladesh's
export is hard hit the government has
urged people to be patient
there was a financial crisis in the wake
of the increase in global fuel prices in
the international market it won't last
long the situation will normalize within
the next 15 to 16 days
analy sworn that with an economic crisis
growing and general elections to be held
in January Bangladesh is likely to see
more protests and unrest in the coming
weeks and months tanvi Chaudhary Al
Jazeera Dhaka